lania fed her horse apples and hugged
him every day until they became best
friends
the seven-year-old says she fell many
times in the last two years
but only cried when the horse was hurt
now the rolling hills in northern iraq's
kurdish region are her racetrack
i hope to open my own teaching school to
ride horses and to teach others i wish
to take part in international
championships my dream is to be a
veterinarian to help horses and to
continue to ride
this horse was a gift from a local
businessman because lania's family
couldn't afford to buy one
international attention has reigned
since the 2003 u.s invasion destroyed
iraq's prestigious horse collection
including thousands of arabian
thoroughbreds
but in the kurdish region three
international events including show
jumping racing and beauty shows were
being held
while they continued during the fight
against isil the event stopped because
of the coronavirus pandemic
with more than 100 members horse riding
has become popular at the only
international club in northern iraq
but to get a spot members must pay a six
thousand dollar yearly fee to access the
stables and facilities
riding is an expensive sport and for
decades iraq's government has paid very
little attention to making it accessible
for everyone even the equestrian
federation is mired under corruption and
internal divisions
the 100 year old iraq equestrian
federation was not able to comment
because of a dispute with the
international federation for equestrian
sports
khalid is a trainer and a veterinarian
and remembers how during his childhood
the government used to pay for
everything he now says he is
disappointed after years of trying to
raise standards and bring together the
iraqi and kurdish equestrian federations
the government of neglected sports in
general not just equestrian they did
nothing for 12 years
they only focused on 10 pegging which is
not an olympic game
iraqi kids have ambitions and we have
open training workshops in schools where
kids can come for affordable rates we
have them as groups and we give them
safety instructions so they are not
deployed of the sport completely
back at the farm lania is hoping to
build on her talent and passion and
represent her village and country
internationally
but with no formal help or training that
dream may require a miracle to come true
[Music]